だから小木ママは進歩せんやろいつまたっ
てもヘリこねとるばっかりで自分が正しい
と言うなら俺と競争してみろ俺がいつも
言うやろお前できるのできんことを正しい
というなこれが現場やぞ逃げずに俺と討論
会開け豪快であんたママだけど男でしょ
それでも男
でしょ本題に入る前なんですけどなんか
ママさんとは昔から対談を希望されてた
みたいなのを伺ったんですけどこの辺に
ついてお話伺ってもいいです
か
うんこちらから申し込むんだけど絶対受け
んのや逃げてばっかりおってさちょうど
その日は詰まっとるからなとかいう逃げ方
よいつでもええからあんたの都合のいい日
言え言ったそしたらこの3年間は1日さり
とも空いてない言って返事が来てあるいは
あんたと私は意見が違うんだから討論して
もしょうがない意見が違うから討論するん
やろそういう言い方するよ大体ねあれは
横着やないあれ日教さやったらね自分たち
が教育をダメにしておいてそのダメになっ
た教育を直そうとする人間を攻撃する何を
しとるんや二重の意味で日本をだめに
しようとしとるん
だママさんがフジテレビでとヤット
スクールが最近取り上げられた時に
コメントをされてるんですねでちょっと
記事の読み上げになってしまうんですけど
今から小ママのコメントをそのまま読むの
でそれについて意見をそのまま伺いたい
です読みますねはいタバというのは今の
時代に全くそぐわない時代錯誤と言えると
思いますしるっていうことはどういうこと
かと言うと説明するってこなんです叩くの
は痛いから我慢してやめるだけそれは愛の
力でも暴力とは違うということでもないな
ので体罰は良くないそれだけはい体罰とは
何かが全然分かってないじゃん体罰の
メカニズムも分かってないやったことも
わけやろ地合一に反するじゃないやってみ
て良かった悪かったをまず決めよで体罰
反対なら反対ってすりゃええんだ全然やら
ずにおいてあのリベラルの哲学イチ哲学
それに基づいてものを言って説得性がある
わけないじゃんね時代錯誤っていう部分は
どうですか今の時代に全く阻まない時代
錯誤っていう部分自分たちでそう決めたん
じゃんだからほんの最近まで体罰はやっ
とったんや法律で禁止されとるからって
言っとるよ明人の時代から法律で禁止され
とったんや体罰はそれなのにずっとやっ
とったんや効果があるからやっとったん
じゃないか古い人はそいつをなんかこう
綺麗事を言う人が子供を嫌がらせてはいか
ん恐怖や怒り不快感を発生させてはいかん
と言いだした体罰をやると不快感が発生
するだからいかんのだと不快感が大事なん
だその不快感でも持って行動する会を求め
不快を避けるだから不快感は人間を行動さ
せる行動して結果進歩するんやないかその
不快感を取っちまえというのが安らの
言い分やろだったら進歩するなというのと
一緒やあゴキブがまた来ちゃいました大体
哲学なんて何の役に立つんだ老人の田ご
みたいなことを信じるやつがあるか実際に
それが正しいという証拠を作ってから
信じろやしかも自分たちに都合のえとこ
ばっかり取るわけやろさっきも言ったよう
に科学というのは再現性のことその法則に
従って行動すれば期待した成果が出てくる
これが科学なんだだからやってみないと
分からんそいつをやりもしないでこうなる
に違いないという哲学へ小ママのやつに
ついてちょっと補足なんですけど文章読む
感じ小ママさんの意見だとしと体罰が別物
っていう風におっしゃって
ます本題ちゃ町会やも学校教育法の中に
教師は町会権を持つって書いてあるんやだ
けどその町会の中の1つ体罰は禁止するっ
て書いてあるんやということは体罰は教育
だということやないかなんで禁止するんや
その理由は知っとるそうやろおも知らんの
や子供というのは神の子なんや想像論だ
から子供は神の子それを人間ごときが殴る
とは何事だというのが体罰禁止の理由じゃ
ないかや教さがれ一応荻さんキスト教のタ
ごえかあれは理論でもない競技想像論か来
とるんだからそもそも科学じゃ
ないゴキブリが気になっちゃったゴキブ
ごときで逃げるんじゃないこれはだめ
だじゃすいません一瞬小木ままさんのお
話してもいいですかママさん曰くしって
いうのは説明して理解させることで体罰
っていうのは叩いて痛いから我慢して
やめるもちろんよそれ狙っとるんやから
痛いから行動するこれだってええんだよ
行動したら進歩する正しい行動やらといか
んけどね分からせようとしとるわけやない
んやで進歩させようとしとるんだよだから
小は進歩せんやろいつまたってもヘリこね
とるばっかりでもし自分が正しいと言う
なら俺と競争しママはしりもせずにしより
褒めろない褒めてばっかりで子供を
ちゃんと教育してみろ俺は褒める光る罰
全部使って教育するからどっちがうまく
いくか競争したらええじゃんヘリばっかり
言ってごを並べとったらいかん実際にやれ
俺がいつも言うやろお前できるのできん
こと正しいというなこれが現場や
ぞ最後に見てるかもしれないんでん
メッセージだけいだいてもいいですかお
まま逃げずに俺と討論会開け公開で体罰の
ことしか言えんだろうちは言うことは
1000でも万でもあるぞだから体罰は
もう意見が絶対に合わんのやからそこに
焦点を合わせずに他のとこでやろうよ教育
について40年前と同じように45年前か
体罰反対ばっかり言っとるんじゃない
あんたらが体罰反対を言い続けたおかげで
どれほどのもう何百万の人間が人生をダメ
にしとるんや進歩の能力がつんやったん
責任取れるの自分の言うことが間違っとっ
たらどういう責任を取るか言えよそれだけ
の覚悟を持ってものを言えあんたママだ
けど男でしょそれでも男でしょ
[音楽]
T
JA